the chelsea owner roman abramovich has
become the latest russian oligarch to
have his assets frozen by the uk
government as part of sanctions over the
war in ukraine in a statement outlining
those sanctions the government said
abramovic is associated with a person
who is or has been involved in
destabilizing ukraine and undermining
and threatening the territorial
integrity sovereignty and independence
of ukraine namely vladimir putin with
whom abramovic has a close had excuse me
a close relationship for decades
well joining me now is kaveh sorhikov
from sky sports news um kevin thanks a
lot for joining us a lot of reaction on
social media to to this and the top
question is what does this mean for
chelsea well look effectively chelsea
are in limbo they're only operating uh
because they have a special license from
the government because the governments
say they are a significant cultural
asset so basically what that means is
these sanctions are designed to stop
roman abramovich making any money in the
united kingdom but obviously he owns
chelsea football club and the government
don't want to get involved in a
situation where they shut down
chelsea so they've given the club a
special license and the license is going
to be in place until the 31st of may and
effectively what it means is that they
can carry on playing games fulfilling
their fixtures
but there are a lot of things that they
can't do and there are a lot of things
that they can do so they can play games
their games can be shown on tv they can
continue to receive tv money they can
carry on paying their players they can
carry on paying day-to-day bills
but the things they can't do
they can't sell any more tickets to
their games at home so the only people
who'll be able to go to stamford bridge
to watch them are people who already
have tickets or people who have season
tickets they also will not be able to
sell any merchandise so their club shops
will have to close
and also there are
lots of
details about how much money they're
allowed to spend so for instance at home
games they're allowed to spend up to
five hundred thousand pounds per game
providing uh stewarding security and
also refreshments so you'll still be
able to buy food and drink at stanford
bridge when it comes to away games
they're only allowed to spend up to 20
000 pounds on travel now
i think that's going to be pretty
difficult for premier league club to
stick to because uh these clubs their
players are used to traveling everywhere
how much do they usually spend well i
think you know ballpark figure 30 000
pounds but when they play uh a lot of
times they fly a fly by private jet to
games
they have luxury coaches when it comes
to champions league games in europe they
stay at the best hotels they have their
own
chartered plane to fly them everywhere
so
that i'm struggling to see how they're
going to be able to stick to that but
that is what it says in the license and
when it comes to the future of the club
i mean there's so many question marks
because
uh you know i know some chelsea players
they will be thinking today my god what
is happening how am i going to
be paid in the future am i going to go
did you say this it goes up to may but
the government say that it's being
continually reviewed uh so that is when
it is in place at the moment but that
could change
so as the players are concerned very
uncertain they don't know what's going
to happen to them in the future a lot of
them will be on their phone to their
agents maybe thinking chelsea's not the
right club for me i should be moving
somewhere else roman ravich is
not going to be running the club we're
not going to have as much money as we
used to as far as roman ravish himself
is concerned of course he has been on
the back foot from day one uh
as soon as it became apparent that there
was the threat of sanctions he's been
trying to sort something out with
chelsea what steps in place didn't he
what did he do well the first thing he
did is he came up with a scheme where he
apparently was going to give away
control of the club but retain ownership
and the control was going to be handed
over to the six trustees who run
chelsea's charitable arm the chelsea
foundation any problem with that is that
under uk charity laws that was not
allowed and also the trustees didn't
want to get involved in running a
business as big as chelsea especially a
business that was owned by a russian
oligarch so that plan didn't work a few
days later he released a statement
saying that okay i'm going to sell
chelsea and i'm going to give all the
money away so yeah he said he was going
to give it i mean which was absolutely
incredible because chelsea
most people think chelsea are worth
somewhere between 1.5 and 3 billion
pounds billion billion pounds so for a
businessman to come out and say i'm
going to sell it and give the money away
and he said i'm going to give the money
to a foundation that i'm going to set up
and this foundation is going to benefit
the victims all the victims of the war
in ukraine wasn't clear how he was going
to be able to set up a bank account
because obviously he's a russian
oligarch who's linked to vladimir putin
it wasn't clear how he was going to be
able to get the money how he was going
to be able to sell chelsea when so many
russian banks and businesses are
under sanctions so that plan doesn't
look like it's going to work either
because the government have said that
this license means that he will not be
able to sell chelsea for the time being
so the sale is off but there is a way
around it the government have said that
uh if he wants to sell it as long as he
can prove that the proceeds are not
going to him
the government may be able to issue a
new license which would allow the club
to be sold but he would have to prove
absolutely and satisfy the government
that he wasn't getting the proceeds so
the sale looks to be off it looks uh the
club are in total limbo and effectively
they're really being run by the
government yeah because that was my my
next question who's running chelsea well
they are running the only reason they're
operating is that they have this special
license from the government it's never
been issued before i'm assuming it's i
i've never heard of anything happening
like this what i think the problem the
government had is they didn't want to
take over control of chelsea because if
they seize all roman rambush's assets it
would effectively mean that the
government would be running chelsea and
the taxpayer would be subsidizing
chelsea because chelsea lose a lot of
money last year they lost something like
150 million pounds so if we had the
situation whereby the government was
running chelsea you would have taxpayers
coming out and saying
why are my taxes going towards paying
romelu lukaku 300 000 pounds a week i'm
a taxpayer i don't want my money going
to pay these millionaire footballers you
fly on private jets who are prime pilot
jets around the world so i think what
the government have done is quite clever
is they've managed to sort of take a
step back and distance themselves from
owning and running chelsea but really
the only reason chelsea is continuing to
operate and the only reason they'll be
able to play their game against norwich
tonight is because they have a license
to carry on playing which has been
issued by the government and the
government have made it clear they can
take that license away anytime they want
when he said he was going to sell it was
there any interest in it
there's been lots of interest but the
whole issue has been is from a pr point
of view it was great for roman ramovich
to say
i'm going to sell chelsea and i'm going
to give three billion pounds away to the
victims of this war although he never
made it clear whether it was just going
to be uh the money was going to
ukrainians or russians as well in
ukraine
so i had the feeling that it was a bit
of a pr move as far as he was concerned
i've never heard of any businessman ever
selling something worth three billion
pounds and giving all the proceeds away
as to interest there was a lot of
interest
we know of at least 10 parties who are
interested in buying chelsea 10 but none
of them were willing to pay 3 billion
pounds most of the interest
came from the us historically the kind
of people who are interested in buying
premier league clubs have been from
russia have been from china because they
had the cash right yeah and also it
helps them
um soften their image and project soft
power around the world a lot of interest
from the middle east as well in this
case there's been virtually
no interest obviously from russia
there's no interest from china because
chinese government have clamped down on
foreign investment very little interest
from the middle east there was some
interest in europe
and also a lot of interest from american
sports investors who want to buy premier
league clubs we've already got eight
premier league clubs who are owned all
co-owned
by americans and i think in the future
we're probably looking at chelsea being
owned
by a u.s businessman sports investor but
that could be months and months away
yeah it's going to be interesting
tonight um against norwich you say thank
you cover thanks a lot fascinating thank
you